[Musique]
et cette invitée aujourd'hui c'est vous
Marianne matarbonucci bonjour bonjour
vous êtes historienne merci beaucoup
d'être là professeur d'histoire
contemporaine à l'université Paris 8
spécialiste du fascisme je le disais à
l'instant c'est un séisme politique à la
fois en Italie et en Europe la coalition
emmenée par l'extrême droite italienne
et donc la arrivée largement en tête des
législatives d'hier dimanche Georgia
Meloni devrait devenir l'équivalent de
Première ministre en Italie c'est la
première fois qu'un parti post fasciste
néopaschiste on va revenir dans un
instant sur les termes parce qu'ils sont
importants se retrouvent aux portes du
pouvoir en Europe depuis la fin la
Seconde Guerre mondiale
que vous inspire d'abord ces résultats
bien vous avez dit je crois justement
que c'est un séisme on avait encore du
mal il y a quelques années à imaginer
qu'un parti
issu de la tradition néo-fasciste puisse
arriver en tête au pouvoir
on s'y attendait en même temps
d'une certaine façon c'est pas plus mal
que le résultat soit nette et donc voilà
ce parti qui était dans l'opposition
depuis quelques années va arriver au
pouvoir nous sommes dans un contexte
démocratique donc les électeurs pourront
juger ensuite sur la base d'une action
de gouvernement alors c'est important de
savoir de quoi on parle de qui on parle
de quel bois politique et constituée
Georgia Meloni est-ce qu'elle est de la
droite radicale est-ce qu'elle est ultra
conservatrice est-ce qu'elle est néo
fasciste alors elle se présente comme
étant à la tête d'un parti conservateur
moi je pense qu'il est plus juste de
parler de droite radicale populiste en
l'occurrence post fasciste non parce que
il y a encore dans une partie de la
culture politique des militants des
cadres et la sienne propre un
héritage du fascisme néo-fasciste non
plus parce que le fascisme n'est pas à
l'ordre du jour mais la mémoire du
fascisme continue à imprégner une partie
de la culture politique de Georgia
Meloni et des militants sachant qu'il
faut rappeler d'où elle vient d'où son
parti vient je vais vous laisser le
faire bien sûr héritier du fameux MSI et
d'ailleurs dont l'emblème est resté la
même tout à fait donc c'est elle vient
en fait son parti aujourd'hui s'appelle
fratelliard qui est lui-même
issu d'une formation qui avait été créée
en 95 à Léan de sa nationale et elle
même née du parti néo-fasciste créé en
1946 le mouvement social italien qui
avait été créé vraiment par des
militants fascistes qui voulaient faire
vivre l'idée du fascisme alors ce parti
a peu à peu près ces distances avec le
fascisme historique sans jamais rompre
totalement il y avait en particulier un
slogan d'admirante qui avait été le le
fondateur de ce parti qui était ni
renier ni revendiquer donc ils sont
toujours restés dans cette entre deux si
vous voulez alors il y a eu lors de des
épisodes de la campagne électorale des
moments où certains ont fait le salut
fascisme discrètement mais quand même la
flamme tricolore que l'on voit
effectivement a été conservée par
Georges Amelo Nice qui était quand même
une façon de ne pas larguer complètement
les amarres avec ce passé là en même
temps il est clair qu'il s'inscrivent
dans le jeu de la démocratie libérale et
qu'ils vont respecter on peut l'espérer
en tout cas les institutions il y a ce
triptyque quand même Dieu patrie famili
la flamme on l'a rappelé à l'instant
qu'est-ce que Georgia Meloni a fait du
corpus idéologique précisément du
fascisme dit historique vous le disiez
il ne s'agissait sans doute pas de
d'appliquer un régime ou en tout cas
d'essayer d'aller de tendre vers un
totalitaire mais quand fait-elle de
cette de ce passer là oui vous avez bien
fait de parler de Régine totalitaire je
crois que c'est pas ça n'est pas
effectivement à l'ordre du jour en
revanche il y a un certain nombre de
valeurs qui étaient des valeurs mises en
avant par le fascisme qui sont
d'ailleurs pas propre au fascisme et que
le fascisme avait radicalisé qu'elle
reprend son compte alors ce qui est
peut-être frappant dans la campagne
électorale c'est à quel point elle a mis
en avant le christianisme mais le
christianisme non pas au sens de la
démocratie chrétienne c'est à dire de la
tradition des populaires italiens mais
un christianisme qui est un
christianisme d'une certaine façon de
combat
ethnorascial pour ne pas dire Europe
blanche en quelque sorte on parle d'un
christianisme un christianisme qui est
un christianisme d'exclusion et ça c'est
quelque chose qui peut être inquiétant
parce qu'on retrouve des discours de ce
type là dans d'autres pays d'Europe
notamment en gris comme vous le savez
chez Victor Hormann en Pologne également
comment expliquer vous expliquer vous
que cette digue avec un scénario par
exemple qui paraît inenvisageable en
Allemagne comment cette digue là et puis
sauter en Italie alors il y a une
fatigue démocratique en Italie comme
dans de nombreux pays d'Europe et pas
seulement d'ailleurs
peut-être d'autant plus accusé que
depuis une trentaine d'années en gros
depuis les années 90 depuis qu'on se
trouve dans ce que certains appellent la
deuxième république même s'il y a pas eu
de changement de Constitution on est
dans une espèce de recomposition
permanente de la vie politique et on
finit par ne plus ne plus comprendre
grand chose les coalitions se font se
défend autour de personnes et au fond
georges jameloni était la seule qui
avait un noyau idéologique à peu près
identifiable et je crois que ça a été la
force effectivement de sa de sa campagne
ensuite elle a beaucoup joué sur des
peurs elle a agité des peurs la question
de l'insécurité la question de
l'immigration également et là on
retrouve aussi autour de ces deux thèmes
là et bien ce qui fait le fonds de
commerce de ces mouvements donc
d'extrême droite populiste en Europe et
ailleurs qui voudrait dire qu'il s'agit
en tout cas en partie dans votre temps
autant d'adhésion quoi que de
protestations exactement il y a cette
double dimension là
protestation parce qu'il y a aussi
probablement une partie d'un électorat
populaire donc il s'est porté aussi sur
le mouvement 5 étoiles et sur le piddy
mais il y a donc l'expression d'une
d'une crainte d'une forme de
nationalisme qui est effectivement
important
aujourd'hui en Italie avec cette
beaucoup de questions notamment on en
parlait avec notre correspondant à Rome
vous le rappeliez l'instabilité de la
vie politique italienne ces dernières
années une question de la pérennité d'un
éventuel gouvernement mené par Meloni
Natalie amendoza rappelait que pour le
coup les partenaires de Meloni la Ligue
et Forsa Italia ont dégringolé par
rapport aux élections précédentes et
c'est un mariage de raison mais sur des
lignes pour le coup politique qui
peuvent diverger quoi oui alors
l'instabilité moi je nuancerais un tout
petit peu quand même parce que si on
regarde justement les dernières années
elle est pas si forte que ça dans la
longue durée oui mais là elle est quand
même pas si forte que ça effectivement
alors on a beaucoup parlé de Georgia
Meloni mais je dirais que ces alliés ne
sont pas forcément plus rassurants d'un
point de vue démocratique pensons à
silvo berlusco ni bon qui est
aujourd'hui un monsieur très âgé qui a
86 ans
qui est toujours là donc je dirais que
ça nuance quand même fortement
l'exigence de renouveau qui
explique en partie le vote de Georgia
mélo ni mais n'oublions pas quand même
ce qui a été le passé de silo Berlusconi
et les casseroles qui sont les siennes
en terme de corruption demeure etc et
berlouzconi voudrait devenir président
du Sénat donc ça c'est pas un très bon
signe quand même de santé démocratique
pensons également à
Salvini qui est affaibli puisque il est
en dessous de la barre des 10% en fait
ces voix ce sont elle a pris énormément
de voix aussi bien à Salvini qu'à
forçait Italia mais Salvini a quand même
soutenu Poutine c'est quelqu'un qui peut
tenir des discours qui pour le coup ne
sont pas forcément des discours
respectueux du droit notamment du droit
international on l'a vu
sur la question des migrants là où elle
effectivement à Meloni elle a un
discours atlantiste en tout cas en
apparence quoi et ce qui nous mène à
cette dernière question on a on en
parlait tout à l'heure les menaces
exprimaient clairement d'Ursula fan de
derrière la semaine dernière sur les
pays qui ne respecteraient pas l'état de
droit et suivez mon regard elle parlait
bien sûr de l'Italie qu'elle place cet
Italie menée par l'extrême droite
pourrait avoir dans en Europe oui alors
je pense que les menaces qui viennent de
l'étranger c'est plutôt contre-productif
ça peut être d'ailleurs c'est très
possible
il y a effectivement un danger je dirais
pour pour l'Europe parce que son projet
clairement assumé et celui de d'essayer
de pousser vers une Europe souverainiste
c'est à dire que là on est quand même
dans l'involution d'un processus
historique allait vers plus
d'intégration européenne
merci beaucoup merci infiniment à
Marianne Matar Bonucci d'être venu ce
matin sur le plateau de France 24
historienne spécialiste du fascisme